hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
who is with me today tell them your name
hello my name is Amy Arbor
Amy our burn is here if you guys have
joined the real rejects from the YouTube
channel chebika way odds are you would
have seen Amy before we've met
twice I think I think yeah and I've seen
you a lot of my brothers Channel
everyone loves you and I said I need all
real her in to the real rejects and then
have her decide who she likes more yeah
post filming poll will be posted on her
youtube channel what amy has a youtube
channel now I do you guys should go
check it out we do it's super exciting
I'm subscribed yes he's a thank you
that's what I wanted was the attention
for subscribing thank you I only have a
couple videos up there now but my launch
date is October 4th but you guys should
subscribe now that way he notified when
it's up Amy have you seen the channel
quarter crew am I about to corner crew
is an amazing YouTube channel they're
one of my favorites they have this
segment here called stuntmen react to
bad and great Hollywood stunts I won't
tell you much more I just want to show
it to you use your incredibly soft
spoken and PR beliefs or a or ASMR that
it is the Billy okay
keep a lookout for her channel people
it's gonna change
I mean that was wire daddy for sure crap
how we so what they did is so except for
your one Squarespace for bringing you
today's episode we've worked with
Squarespace - you can get 10% here first
purchase welcome back to that men react
here with Lyndon he's joined us again to
give us some great insight into the
world of stunts and some crazy things
you guys mean out of her stall so it's
gonna be I think it's gonna be a good
one but yeah god I sure wish you guys
had a bigger couch here click on fire
now this video is probably come out
always after that one but if you haven't
seen it
gently go check that out okay okay oh I
loved this movie as well
[Music]
talking directly to that it's really
awesome stunt-driving information isn't
driving on feel I got the whole time
okay seem to pick up middle guys are
[Laughter]
highly souped-up car to be able to do
these types of slides times the stuffs
tested and like say a parking lot or on
a track manholes different variations
into concrete everything else you have
to get some people that are like the
best in the business
some of these slides I mean he's pushing
this so far it's like unbelievable
Wow I'm assuming that this was a pursuit
vehicle and it has this massive Russian
right type thing on top of it these guys
are stuntmen in their own right the guy
who is operating that Russian arm really
knows where he can be he can kind of
pull it up and the car will go
underneath it when you pull that off you
would expect it like jump out of the car
we're gonna do it again he just gets on
the radio he's like copy going back to
one gnarly driving
that was Ansel Elgort doing that pose
there so that he can lose traction on
the absolutely the puddles are actually
like fairly strategically placed oh how
interesting Sian that's pretty slick how
much says those trucks aren't there
right there the one that's backing up
yeah but you don't tell the motion yeah
we move that this guy who's doing is
insane like he's got these walls and
he's able to even pull that off I Drive
like that in North Hollywood the best
part of this movie
closest I've ever come to using a gun
right there I love that they grab his
cave the worst thing that you can have
is a vigilante escape you have this
inherent problem where you need to get
rid of people's guns and I think it was
a pretty creative way to use one of his
gadgets to kind of like disarm as many
of them as it could
I'm gonna go with it that is some sort
of like super hard rubber or so but
still how do you do that underneath it
see how he's kind of Prayer for it his
knees are bent he kind of is not jumping
in the air he's just really straight to
the floor I think that he actually did
go for that for the most part and he's a
nasty stunt man I'm sure he was like
yeah we're going for it do you know
position your body though no does it
make impact softer to break through
stuff totally so then I didn't go to the
launch bounced off it that'd be a bigger
hit than going through the wall I think
crashing through something softens in a
bed
[Music]
ow we can't shoot Batman B he said well
it's nice to see Batman get thrown like
kicking the crap out of everybody and to
see him get overwhelmed and how he deals
with it and gets back to his feets
pretty tired the Kapus you ever had the
after action oh yeah we were doing the
daredevil Punisher fight I mean me and
the stunt guy from daredevil definitely
punch each other he was dared oh it was
Punisher stunt double so we definitely
clipped each other a couple of times but
we laughed bad oh my god I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry you're also kind of like
pulling your punch too so like if you
clip somebody it may not be like where's
MMA conscious all right so we actually
do the stats for these videos in like
60% of the viewers who watch these
videos aren't subscribe to the channel
if you want consider subscribing it
actually helps us out it helps a channel
and it's a great way take the fate of
your video while that's out of the hands
of the algorithm do you want to robot
telling you what to watch or do you want
to decide yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is funny but yeah like thinking it
in the context of stunts yeah I think
that one was a white wire definitely
watered the survivor with her they're
going down the hill those guys just
didn't I mean they did it kind of oh my
god it's we're just
Oh just launching it so off-screen they
probably have like a large pad or
something like that so that like his mom
you stop and not hit a tree or get
really hurt I mean they have to be so
sore the next day I'm tired
for a comedy I mean that guy want to
stop award for that
really Wow
whoa pretty good actually a chance to be
any Samberg like two months ago
oh yeah you're saying that the physical
eyes yourself damn use a shot the same
rule
that's a cool rule oh man he has aged
one bit you really have to have a better
crazy guy like really into he was
skydiving before this oh really you know
they get to when they want to film this
and Swayze wants to jump like he wants
to do it on his own you know for
production reasons they absolutely would
not let him jump so what they did is on
one weekend Swayze literally was like
good buddies with the stunt coordinator
sucking a director and some of those
guys and like that shot right there
they him and his buddies literally just
took the camera and did this rug no
thank you
wasn't actually lazy that's absolute
gold that's amazing you can clearly see
it Tim you can clearly see that ski on
in like on some blue screen there's a
lot a key on does tons would not be
nearly as good
what's this time here yeah I love this
movie you know that's actually what
happens when you get shot you know
people take these huge reactions like
the bullet just goes through pretty much
don't move unless I would say it's like
a super high caliber around from like a
rifle or something like that yeah
awesome I never noticed him water
dude just a great ketchup massacre
Clinton is so good I wish all movie
squibs like that there's a thing that
Digital blood hits like never can do as
much as I love John wick I you know it's
like I wish they would do a little bit
more practical blood and stuff like that
I mean typically with the squid be a
sideshow just gonna talk to you and be
like hey you know it's this much of a
charge he's gonna say it's gonna feel
like you know the light punch or it's
gonna feel like somebody flicking you
like just depending on how much is in
there and you'll get like a pad or you
know you take a flat pad and put it
underneath there yeah and it should
protect you from that the first time we
did squibs we learned that you can't
have people's arms in front of them yeah
there's a little bit of what like
gunpowder in there and it can literally
like burn your honor it's hard though
with a gunfight seems every is aiming or
shooting their guns if they're gonna
take center-of-mass hits it's gonna
blast into your arm so you know it's
like when those guys open the door
notice I'm just one guy just standing
there like this with the gun in his hand
just like wide open like no one has
their arms and from their chests come
shoot me oh cool
[Music]
look at this girl just waiting for her
where she gets pulled Oh does it make
any sense I guarantee that the stunt
coordinator was like look this
completely defies all to do this like
okay I mean I almost was just like
yanked her into the doorway and I didn't
clip off of it you know humor comedy if
you would like to follow Eric's work ask
him questions you can follow him at Eric
Wyndham video overwhelmed last time but
you know what I I promised I would
respond to everybody I responded to well
over 300 messages Wow
how did I personally start so I
literally just for you guys went and
tight [ __ ] gone Squarespace talk
about first place anyways let's take
around to the end of the episode today's
sponsor is Squarespace and I'm gonna
tell you all about how you can get 10%
off your first purchase but first a joke
a businessman a lawyer one person uses
Squarespace can you guess which one it
is businessman are three the answer is
that it's the bartender and the
bartender is the real winner here he was
able to create a beautiful website that
God has sent us the lawyer and the
businessman into his bar in the Frog
ways because he really a joke
[Laughter]
and it did simultaneous a hard thing
contributors to contribute to his
website he didn't just create the whole
website himself he had one of them but
using traffic system this savvy
bartender was able to understand Sammy
burns anyone we all know believe the
minutes great one thing you might not
know is that it's really hard for
lawyers to pass the bar and it's even
more difficult to get lawyers out of
bars unless they commit malpractice
using iron bars think about that one but
anyway what you probably should know is
that this savvy bartender talks to all
those lawyers in his bar and he found
out all of this is the best best monster
ship I've ever seen a mo
and now finally let's make sure we talk
about that businessman that businessman
well he's the smartest one of the bunch
because he went on over to
squarespace.com slash corner crew and he
got 10% off his first purchase that's
right squared space.com slash quarter
Squarespace is great guys hey guys its
Lucas we let you guys know about my
favorite Instagram
in Maine maybe yay and they were the
corridor crew okay I lied I have seen
them before I do deny you white
supremacists
[Laughter]
but no Darren so I'm on board one thing
this channel consistently does for me
every time I watch one of their videos
is remind me of how much I take for
granted when I watch any of these films
because you know it's like especially
when you're like film circles everyone
talks so much about like storytelling as
if that's important it talks about
storytelling in the art of everything
oftentimes action sequences and stuff
that's done minute required for are kind
of just chalked up to just oh she's
action just whatever literally every
second and especially in a movie like
baby driver which is so edited son heavy
you'll miss so much that you're just
like yeah cool and that's it you just go
cool but that took them like such a long
time to put that together you know even
a couple of days to get the shot that
they need it and for everything to go
for Prix Utley I didn't even think that
something like I would have watching
that it first of all it happens in two
seconds and I think are you just assumed
to the untrained eye it's not a stunt
it's like computer magic happening that
was actually a dude in a car it's hard
to even fathom and it must take so much
rehearsal in so much time and it happens
in literally like what was that scene 5
seconds 10 seconds show me well yeah
five seconds long yeah so much oh my
gosh
just expertise and time and particular
yeah it's like sometimes they have to
say they were talking about that truck
that's like CGI'd in to come provide
environment yeah they were like it's
obvious obviously cheap ass move
how is it obviously maybe I wasn't
paying close enough attention but
they're going frame by frame their
visual effects artist so I'm sure they
could pick up on like these little
details that we might not see I always
love it when I when he I do learn that
the actors really did train yeah I
remember the like for the Matrix
Reloaded carrie-anne moss to do all the
motorcycle training in the car stunts
they had to CGI a lot of like in the
freeway of the other cars but she really
did learn how to do the the motorcycle
stuff Anza allegory I'm here clearly
that to some time which is absurd
attractive points dude it really said
the thing is I'd be afraid to be a part
of a movie like this because I know what
I would be like in real life if I got
this kind of training yeah I would get
so much in my Toyota Camry 2006 edition
let's get on the road and show you yeah
do things it doesn't usually do and then
for fight scenes like this they didn't
even break down in the Batman one how
that guy did that fall they broke down
what he was falling on to but not the
actual like they talked about the rubber
ground yeah which is a necessity
obviously but how do you mean help how
do you train to fall as if you're
slamming your neck to the ground like
that he was obviously prepped to do it
but just like to do that without
actually hurting yourself would you do
something like this would you take fight
training Amy oh I would love to take
fight training absolutely cuz then you
look like a badass without actually
having to fight anyone that's real
that's true it's ideal amazing what
fight choreography can do for you hot
rod man this was a curveball did not see
this coming
but again you take it for it like a hot
rod as a stunt movie when it's about a
guy who's doing stunts essentially you
know oh yeah yeah but you don't know
you're absolutely right though cuz I
don't I don't factor that in either it
is funny because they have this
professional stunt coordinator here
stunt man on the hot rod once the comedy
this was the ones where he was like
wonder how he's like big-budget movies
he's like here's what they did
but then for this really hot rod is the
one that's the most contemplative one
actually like a person actually went on
a bike and he crashed into a platform
for that moment I don't know I maybe
would have attributed that to the
computer magic also beforehand because
we tribute so much wits not work to like
you know great action scenes to enhance
realism and stuff and this is the first
time I've seen a corridor true video
that took a comedy movie they put their
lives on the line too so we could
chuckle at a moment in the movie that's
so awesome
I've actually been on set first before
it was not someone on a motorcycle
flying over anything but it was someone
who had to appear to be getting hit by a
car and they actually did throw
themselves I mean so I related to they
mentioned here that everyone on set was
like oh and that is what it's like on
set sometimes you're watching the stunt
person and you're like art thumping
moment luckily the person was okay and
this one was too - a broken femur yeah I
want an award award and I was just about
to say they should be rewarded yeah yeah
we give it to them again 2019 award
actual people do these things the squibs
of a Django Unchained have you learned
have you had to deal with the squid yeah
the blood exploiting yeah no the sea
creatures haven't either a sea creature
of going along with a squids whatever
squid yeah you never had to deal with
the spoon before no but I would like to
I was just in a short film that we were
shooting out in the desert I had to get
shot the squib was not working so they
had to actually put it in my hand and
then I had to like keep squeezing it
myself as if he's blood gushing out of
me and then there was another part or
the part where I actually get shot that
guy in charge of the blood because he
couldn't get the script of work I
basically had to block him out of frame
and I get shot he had to like push down
this thing so though he could see blood
on the actor who is
I had to like block his frame it's
really hard work like dealing with
squibs is it's it's weird it's easily
gonna be like no problem yeah when
you're acting it has to be so timed with
the script going off camera timing the
squib for you yeah there's there's a
dude off-camera so it's like dudette
when you get shot I imagine winning ish
I've never been shot yeah I mean who
knows maybe one day for her brownie
points encourage any subscribers well
Greg I just imagine that when you get
shot you're gonna like if it's not a
scene where you're really anticipating
you're gonna get shot supposed to be
unexpected yeah and so you're supposed
to have a reaction where it's like you
have to act like you're not prepared
that it's gonna happen but you also have
to be prepared that it's going to happen
it's kind of a it's a weird choreography
to handling squibs and stuff but even in
this scene when they broke down with
Django whether they're talking about the
script coming in the front and out the
back it's like I'm watching it happen
and it's cool when you're like filming
it and you're on set with something like
that that's something that you're like
that's gold man that's gold but most
audiences will just be like cool and
literally yeah well because you see it
for three seconds yeah it just happened
so quickly you can't even appreciate the
moment gosh but boy do we do we cuz
we're better than all of you or were
more the best essentially or the best we
just have a better eye and I can't end
this video without talking about Patrick
Swayze taking it upon himself
I mean we always now adays we have a lot
about Thomas the cruise yes what am i
Heroes Tom Cruise jumping out of planes
I mean he did a crazier one for Mission
Impossible fall out but the fact that
they wouldn't let him do it
so he's like we're just gonna shoot the
scene I feel like nowadays they were
good soon like I would have loved to be
there for the moment of so guess what we
did again we got the footage for you is
that only do they have to get the
footage but they have to make the
footage match or whatever else the
shooting oh my gosh just like the
commitment again commitment that's
beautiful and fun fact yeah that's
amazing actually jumps out of the plane
and wasn't supposed to was not planned
that is badass man that's really badass
show respect I can't even look out the
top of a roof of a three-story house I
kind of want to jump out of a plane
parachute obviously I don't know why I'm
clarify yeah I would love to jump at how
we'd like to end it I have such a big
fear of heights
I feel like I don't know if I would
conquer my fear or if it would just get
worse yeah you'd be the guy out there
like no I'm sure if I jumped out I would
just black out right away but then you'd
miss the whole way down and that's
supposed to be kind of the best jump I
think it's just the beginning guys
thanks for being here if you haven't
subscribed accord or true do it today
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can click our notification valve
more importantly go to Amy our Byrnes
youtube channel subscribe today
she already has a couple of videos up
more content soon to come she will not
return if none of you guys subscribe so
subscribe if you want her to come back
to the real rejects and I'd like to come
back to the real rejects I only wish to
agree to do it is if she gets at least 5
5 before we wrap this up I would like to
give a patron the day shout out to a man
named Melvin X not his real name I
believe it's Tamir he's an artist he
does a great job he's been one of our
top pledge patrons for such a long time
Amy can you say a thank you to Melvin
expiry add on whatever with your
recently acquired improv skills Oh
oh my okay Melvin X thank you so much
for subscribing to the reel rejects it
is obviously the best rule it is one of
the greatest reaction channels out there
everybody say the best because I know
they're reviewing American sure is it
American content no Greg Alva is just a
fabulous human being appreciated for and
after recording and during malva Knicks
this is your best shot at you every cop
for supporting Greg he's awesome
you